Ian's gonna come by your pressure the
cool last night there like that dude Sam
his name's Anthony or clone Sam oh man
they oh I didn't register any air his
name is Jenna and Tyler Monica and Sam
cool meeting you actually actually you
do this you your horrible name just
never like connect to somebody so fast
make it good friend Sam Sam
look it look like a Sam okay what I
really like that girl Andrea
- there was no Andrews at the party but
Melissa you gotta get better at this I'm
gonna face this guy came out what I
remember faces not name what does that
even mean are there people walking
around that are good at names and not
faces sure
so they're walking around with
catalogues of names and they don't have
any faces to put to them that I don't
know this doesn't make sense just a bad
excuse for being bad at names do it I
don't even do you want to learn or not
do you want to get better at this you're
not wait someone cuts with her name
I say back to that so not only if I
heard it but I've said it yeah you know
something you get it okay yeah so it's
like I'm Chris I'm Gerry I'm Chris
no it's you know Chris you have to say
Jared okay I'll try it on the next
person I mean I'll meet somebody right
now all right I'll just get it don't
worsen a lot confess don't you this
person
Chris that's okay ma'am I'm Chris yeah I
know I met you last night dude that's
camp because somehow no faces guy either
we got another puncher we press pretty
hard